it is my honor and pleasure to welcome
the yang speaks
my good friend the decorated veteran
author combater of poverty
all-around superhero former rhodes
scholar i guess you're always a road
scholar that's the way that [ __ ] works
wes moore west welcome andrew
it's good to see you man it's good good
to be hanging out here with the yang
gang man i'm uh
i'm thankful for this i've been looking
for this for a long time man i'm proud
of you
well you and me both and we have so much
to talk about
yeah you know uh um i saw you when i was
just starting to
run for president when it was a little
bit more
crazy shall we say
and you know it's funny i tell people i
will never forget
that meeting um where where you came up
to the office of robin hood
we're talking about poverty which almost
worked and and so then i asked you a
question like so what are you up to and
you said you know
i think i'm gonna run for president and
i remember taking that pause like
wait is he serious right now or is he
saying something supposed to react
and then when you when when i realized
you were serious i remember getting up
and giving you a hug
because i was like this is so i mean
it's it's so unbelievably bold and brave
and beautiful
and and when you think about it in in
respect of
where we are as a nation and what we
need
you know we've got to be thinking bold
we got to be thinking brave on this
stuff
because it's uh i think that's kind of
what the moment uh you know it's what
the moment
requires and ask for so i will i will
never forget
uh exactly where we were in my office
and where we're sitting when you first
told me
that you were running for president yeah
and that was one of the
best reactions i got thank you guys i
remember it too
you know my biggest question for u.s is
a personal one
i've known you for years and your
biography is remarkable it's the stuff
of
you know almost too good to be true made
for tv movie type stuff like jumping out
of planes
defending the country trying to fight
poverty at the scale
you're fighting it um i've been in rooms
with you i've been in similar rooms
um and that there were times when i felt
like
and this would be more extreme for you
than would be for me uh because
you know like and and when i was running
for president i actually kind of
realized a little bit of like the role i
was feeling like the persona
um like in your case you're like the
walking inspirational
like hey uh like i'm like the embodiment
of the american dream
um like as a as a leader who's come out
of really difficult
circumstances and and now is someone
that everyone looks to for inspiration
um the personal question is like when i
was in those rooms there were times when
i just felt like screaming my head off
like where like i have that role and
like you know
particularly when i was the head of a
non-profit because
you were continuously there was like
this
you know dynamic you had where it's like
and now here's inspirational nonprofit
leader
uh and then i'm like okay like i will
now play my role to the best of my
ability
um and then you will give me this
um grant maybe if i'm lucky or i did a
good job
and then whatever size the grant is then
like i act like it's the greatest thing
in the world
like even if you know maybe like i was
hoping for something a little different
or bigger
um and and so that there were
times like when i really struggled
personally
now i've known you for years and i've
never really felt from you
like like anything but like 100 like
functional uh sincerity really like you
know like
like you always seem to be inhabiting
yourself and very present um
so i'm just wondering whether or how you
deal with
like any of those uh thoughts or
pressures if you have them or if i'm
just projecting my own
struggles onto you brother uh it is it
is it is an
everyday thing um and but i realized too
it's an everyday thing for all of us
right
and and actually and i i give you i give
you a lot of praise in the fact that you
own it
i think there's a lot of people who walk
around like it's not real like it's not
this i mean
um transparency and and
transparency and humility are incredibly
powerful particularly to see in people
that i admire like you because the
reality is that
that pressure is real and
and i think that part of the thing that
i think that kind of keeps me
in a level of center and and and i know
it does for you as well
is we do walk around knowing that
our narratives our stories
when you consider our backgrounds and
our journeys
are unlikely that we weren't the people
who came from you know this was not a
quote unquote
societal birthright this was something
that
there were people in our lives
family members friends mentors coaches
etc
who in many ways saw something in us
before we could even see it in ourselves
and i think about in the case of like my
grandfather
where my grandfather was actually the
the first one on my mom's side of the
family born in this country was born in
charleston south carolina
but he wasn't raised here and the reason
was because when he was just a toddler
the ku klux klan ran him
and the rest of my family out of this
country not just out of charleston south
carolina because my gran my great
grandfather was a minister and he's a
very vocal minister
and eventually the verbal threats became
physical ones and he
picked up his family in the middle of
the night and he left this country
and uh and the majority of my family you
know they they vowed to never
come back here and they didn't my
grandfather did
my grandfather was the only one who came
back to the united states
and started his family here with my
great-grandmother was actually from cuba
and they came to the south bronx where
he was a minister the first black
minister in the history of the dutch
former church my grandmother was a
school teacher
in the south bronx for almost 30 years
and i think about it in context of this
where
this was a man who
was forced out of this country when he
was just a child some of his earliest
memories
were america's ugliest moments
and he loved this country like no one i
knew
and i think about and part of the reason
i have to tell you andrew why i
why when you told me that my first gut
reaction was that you're running my
first
reaction was to hug you because what
else are we supposed to be doing
like this country is an extraordinarily
exp
it's an extraordinarily special
experiment
and it's something that every drop of
progress has been hard
earned it has not been inevitable
and it's something that needed to happen
because the words of this country were
not matching up
to its practices its ideals and its
values
were not matching up to its practices
and so every single bit of progress that
we have made in this country has been
hard earned and it's been hard fought
for
and what choice do we have particularly
considering
the past and the legacies that we come
from
but to fight but to stand up and be
a portion as brave as my grandfather was
as your family was have a portion of the
bravery
and the courage and the loyalty and the
patriotism
that they had and so this i mean this is
this is hard stuff man and sometimes
there is a level this this our the place
that we call home
will leave us with a level of
frustration that is sometimes
indescribable
our job isn't to stay there though our
job is to remember
not just why we're here but the progress
we have made
and to know that if that progress is
going to continue it's
on us we're not responsible for where
things are right now
but the truth is if they're like that 20
years from now that is our cross to bear
that is on us and that's what i just
take seriously well you certainly
embody that through your action your
career
uh the stories that you've been
amplifying
and sharing with the world it's a
privilege to be your friend wes and
it's going to be a privilege to abolish
poverty alongside you in the days to
come
first in a small part of the country and
then hopefully
society-wide thank you for listening in
i hope you enjoyed this conversation if
you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode